anne vit seule avec ses cinq enfants
dans cette petite maison du quartier
populaire de gonzagueville au sud est
d'abidjan
ici pas télé ni d'internet impossible
pour eux de suivre les cours mis en
place par le ministère de l'éducation
alors parfois aidé par un grand frère du
quartier les enfants temps d'étudier
comme ils peuvent
qui utilise la maison et je comprends
pas ils sont obligés d monacale qu'un
noyau compris mais il n'a pas fait quoi
il ne sait pas lire ne peut pas donner
des coups sur moi qui ai fait lui un peu
étonné de même coup un voilà c'est comme
ça etc les faits les 600 bottes et me
braves à quelques rues de là changement
d'ambiance
emmanuel est un ancien enseignant papa
de deux adolescents trois à quatre fois
par semaine
il leur donne des cours d'anglais pour
faire en sorte qu'ils ne prennent pas de
retard sur le programme
il faut que la flamme éteinte les
choquer les enfants garde toujours en
mémoire ce qu'ils ont appris il faut les
amener à réviser leurs leçons et font
même les eaux des la douleur prendre
certaines choses qui leur manquent ou
alors des techniques qui les empêchait
de comprendre et mieux comprendre classe
et nous sommes en tant que père c'est
notre devoir à nous de la suivre c'est
pas parce que il n'ya plus de classe il
faut les abattre et non il faut les
infos sur son enfant j'avais besoin
d'une personne pour y dénoncer
nous allons commencer d'autres ont
presque de véritables cours dans cette
maison en construction transformée en
salle de classe
un professeur d'une cour à une dizaine
de jeunes qui préparent le baccalauréat
chaque étudiant doit payer un peu plus
de guille euros par mois une somme
importante pour les parents mais qui
permet aux enfants de ne pas décrocher
pendant cette période avec ces
situations la situation sanitaire
beaucoup
c'est parti il ya beaucoup de choses
aussi à régler à la maison et avec cette
notion bon le parfum défaut de pouvoir
payer mais c'est un peu difficile pour
faire en sorte que les enfants ne
décroche pas totalement de l'école c'est
le but des animateurs de l'association
imagine le monde sur le terrain
il accompagne les familles des quartiers
démunis pour que les enfants privés
d'école ne se retrouve pas dans la rue
et ne tombent dans la délinquance
les risques qu'il ya c'est bizarre que
les enfants ne sont pas donc dans la
calanque sécurisé où sont laissés à eux
mêmes
et vu que les parents sont amenés donc à
chercher donc les des ressources ou
aider donc alors la vie quotidienne du
ménage les enfants n'ont plus
d'empattement comme il s'est fait au
niveau de l'école et
le peu qu'ils ont pris à prendre voilà
il n'ya pas de suivi et pour nous c'est
normal même si la décision de fermeture
dont des traces ont été prises dont on
le salue donc de tous il n'en demeure
pas moins que l'accompagnement des
enfants une fois la maison devient
vraiment gros soucis que les parents
permet depuis le 17 mars
les écoles rouvriront finalement la
semaine prochaine a précisé la ministre
de l'éducation nationale